des grands vignobles des paysages
verdoyants et des villages tranquilles
la bourgogne fait le bonheur des
touristes désireux d'échapper au tumulte
des grandes métropoles
même si ce groupe d'amis venus de
marseille a surtout choisi la région
pour ses vins un petit séjour en
bourgogne pour essayer de trouver
quelques bons petits crus pour
agrémenter nos bouillabaisse noble et
autres pieds paquets quoi en transe
gaule mer et l'espace on va dire plus
agréable d'être ici que confiné on avait
en région par exemple est beaucoup
pourrait suivre leur exemple
après l'instauration d'un couvre-feu
pour neuf grandes villes alors que les
vacances de la toussaint démarre ce
week-end en une matinée l'office de
tourisme de beaune a déjà reçu de
nombreux appels pour des séjours de
dernière minute on peut parier sur le
fait que ce sera très positif pour nous
nous ne sommes pas dans la zone du
couvre-feu
nous ne sommes pas en zone renforcée
donc nous avons toute une offre
touristique encore opérationnels au
niveau des hébergements au niveau des
restaurants au niveau des sites et
monuments et surtout au niveau de
l'événementiel d'autant que le pays
beaunois est idéalement situé entre
paris et lyon
dans cet hôtel restaurant spécialisé
dans le tourisme ces grandes villes
représentent 60% de leur clientèle
française
les gérants compte sur ses nouvelles
annonces pour relancer la saison
on va attendre de voir ce qui se passe
mais on se dit en tout cas que dans les
champs des possibles on peut récupérer
un petit peu d'une clientèle que nous
n'avons pas eu depuis le mois de
septembre sur les vacances de la
toussaint est un petit peu au-delà et si
cet effet d'aubaine se confirme cela
pourrait faire du bien aux
professionnels de l'oenotourisme alors
que la clientèle étrangère annuler coup
sur coup